[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hi martin how are you
i'm i'm still doing okay
we're living in serious times
and sometimes serious times calls for
serious talk
yes
so
let's see how this one
goes and where the lord leads us yes
let's see
our heavenly father
we want to give this whole discussion
now into your hands and ask that your
holy spirit
enlighten our minds
and guide the discussion and lead us to
the truth in jesus name i mean amen
martin the title of this one is nothing
against the truth but for the truth
in other words nothing that happens
even if it seems
like the end of the world has come
it cannot destroy the truth
that's for certain because the truth the
truth is on a foundation that cannot be
shaken
now martin
the letters don't stop streaming in
and it is almost as if the events of the
last year
have brought to the four
other issues
yeah
because people are unhappy with one
issue
the snowball has grown and the issue is
escalating
and many many issues are now being added
to the snowball
and eventually the snowball is so big
that people are beginning to say it
cannot be saved
yeah right correct
now
one of the reasons why
we are talking about this issue in the
first place
is because
we get so many requests to talk about it
and some people are
highly
highly upset
about certain issues
now
it's not always possible to contain it
so that it only revolves around one
issue all of the snowball comes together
you it's not separate it's like it's
like a marriage
if an argument occurs
the issue at hand is not the only one
that is raised at that particular
time
but
all the others that have been irritating
for a long time come to the fore as well
how do you deal with it and what do you
do with it
so people have been asking
questions
and some of them are highly upset
and so we will try and address that now
in the last one
we discussed the church
as the apple of the lord's eye the only
object on which he
pours out his supreme regard
we have stated
numerous times
that we believe that this church
has the final message for the world yes
but the fact of the matter is there is
difference of opinion on many issues
and all of these
as i say have been
accumulating and are now somehow wrapped
in this final snowball yes correct
and
maybe this is the devil's doing
but maybe it's also
god's doing
because god wants to have a church that
has one voice
yes that's his main focus and it's very
hard if you look at the world and what's
happening
to conceive how that one voice will come
about
and then we have to ask ourselves
where is the church
now some people
try to
categorize the church
and they would want to say well the
problem is at this level in the church
this level
is apostate
this level is fine
and even at this level there are
differences of opinion
etc
and some will go
so far as to say
that this level of leadership
is at fault
and
the rest
are not at fault or whatever yeah
we've addressed that and i think we have
said quite plainly
that god's people are at every level
in every level it's important to realize
it correct it's been like this
since the beginning since the beginning
and it is also true
that even at different levels even in
different levels of leadership
some of the voices might be stronger
than some of the other voices and it was
like that throughout history
if you take the sanhedrin
that condemned jesus and crucified him
and had him crucified
and involved the state in the
crucifixion
were there members in that
sanhedrin that held it up for
many many times
and eventually
they were ignored and whatever happened
happened right but it happened because
prophecy said it would happen
no matter how much they would have said
they wouldn't have held it up because
prophecy was going to be fulfilled right
but were there good people at that level
yeah
definitely didn't they come out and uh
join the fl fledgling church didn't
nicodemus come out yes didn't joseph
come out yes
and didn't many many of the priests
believe and come out exactly so we
cannot allow
the thought to enter the mind that we
must demonize one category
does that mean that that category is
doing the right thing did the sanhedrin
do the right thing no not at all no it
didn't do the right thing at all
so we have to be very careful how we
argue
so let's just sum up what the main
problems are yes the issues that's
bothering people correct people are
saying
why is the church involved in economical
meetings
why is it sitting in economical councils
why do they
meet
with
the papacy even with the pope directly
on behalf of
the church
why do some
leadership circles in different
countries
involved themselves
in economical councils sit in economical
councils
and are part of the decision-making
forum of those councils
the question is is that an official
position of the church even if it comes
from the highest level is that an
official position no it can't be no it's
not an official position there's a
certain structure that has to
be in place or to be an official and at
every one of these levels leadership
levels is everybody on the same page as
to what they're doing no no
definitely not
otherwise there wouldn't be this
constant conflict and debate regarding
this thing right
people are asking
i'm we're just going now according to
the questions as they come in people are
asking
how can we support a church without
tithes
if they
support let's say
competitive sport
if they are involved in competitive
sport
if they are involved with
world medical councils for example
if they work together with
people that do not follow our health
message as it is described in the spirit
of prophecy
people are asking those questions
and
how can we support a church where we can
see at so many levels that they're
joining hands with babylon this is what
people
are saying
why are they denying the spirit of
prophecy in terms of these things these
are legitimate questions
okay
and one person writes that they can no
longer attend the churches in their area
because there's no more inadverted
commerce a divine servers it says
there's nothing divine about the service
it's uh
the hymns have been replaced it is more
like a concert
than a divine service with drums and
disrespect for
for reverence for god
all of these issues and this is not an
isolated case we get it right throughout
the world right
great so
does that mean now that we put
everything into one bag and say that's
it
so
you know i thought
perhaps if we if we
address it and perhaps
if it will help i can give a little bit
of my experience over the years with
this issue yes how long have you been in
the church well some 33 years now so i'm
sure you can have some stories to tell i
have many stories to tell
and some of them are not very nice
stories
but all of the stories are
important
because they teach you something
and you can make a choice you can make a
choice between two b's
you can become better or you can come
bitter yeah
you can condem
everything
and walk away
or
you can
embrace that which is good
and like moses said
lord blot me from the book of life but
let them live
and many of the stories you know have
such interesting twists to them
because nothing is cut and dried no it
is it is fluid
humanity has to make decisions
and you might be sitting on one side of
the fence today
like paul was yes and the very next day
he was sitting on the other side of the
fence right
how do i know whether god is finished
with this particular person or not and
who am i to judge what is finished and
what is not finished we are not to judge
it it's a fluid dynamic
and whose church is this this is god's
church so
that's he's the owner all right so
when i when i see all of these questions
i can concur because i've been there
and
i've probably been
more involved
than
most people
could even imagine
and
the correspondence between myself and
certain groups is it's volumes
it's volumes
and it's the same battle over and over
and over and over again
and if you take this battle personally
you will be destroyed
i've been in this church for a short
while
and even in the short while i can concur
what you've just said
if you take it personally
then you will definitely not stick you
will be destroyed you will you will be
destroyed you will go into depression
absolutely you will not be able to
survive
so
this battle
is not ours it is the lord's and you can
do nothing against the truth
no you can do only something
for the truth and even that which
appears to be against the truth
is actually for the truth
so
let us open this
this discussion
with a few quotes from the spirit of
prophecy
and then
we'll go down a little walk through
memory lane and see
things maybe from a different
perspective yeah
because you can focus so on what is
wrong
that you cannot see the right
and sometimes you cannot see the outcome
for all the wrong
that's true
so let us see
how this pans out because i want to
assure the viewers
that no matter what happens
god is in control
i mean and god will work out his
purposes
but his modus operandi
is sometimes
to the human mind
incomprehensible it's a little bit
not as you would have thought it no you
would definitely not have done it like
that but in retrospect
it was always the right thing right
let's have a look at the statement in
the in the spirit of prophecy it comes
from the thoughts from the mount of
blessing
controversy that awakens minds
in every age god's chosen messages
have been reviled and persecuted
yet through their affliction the
knowledge of god has been spread abroad
every disciple of christ is to step into
the ranks and carry forward the same
work
knowing that its foes can do nothing
against the truth
but for the truth
that's a beautiful statement
god means that truth shall be brought to
the front and become the subject of
examination and discussion
even through the contempt placed upon it
you cannot say it in a better way you
cannot then there's the hope
in this
in your whole walk yes
the minds of people must be agitated
every controversy
every reproach every effort to restrict
liberty of conscience
is god's means of awakening minds that
otherwise might slumber
so now many people have woken up
because there's been some consternation
in the world
right
and uh
the great reset we're going somewhere
and everybody knows that wherever that
is it's certainly not where god is
leading right no not at all and so all
of these issues have come
to the table
and
let us look at them because at the end
of the day
we need
clarity of mind
in this church and it's as you said in
the previous one do we sweep everything
under the table
do we ignore it and say it doesn't
happen no it does happen it does
but maybe god wants to
bring the discussion to to the front to
the front because i like what you've
just said
we've woken up
many have woken up something has
happened that people are waking up and
some have been stung yes and they're
angry
and
maybe
there has been
for years
don't know how long
all these problems persisting already
yes correct but now with people waking
up it's maybe god's way of
like you just said bringing this out to
the fall correct so let's look how this
works
okay here's another quote from the
spirit of prophecy
the state of corruption and apostasy in
the last days was presented to the
prophet john in the vision of babylon
that great city which reigneth over the
kings of the earth revelation 17 18
before its destruction the call is to be
given from heaven come out of her my
people that you be not partakers of her
sins and that you receive not of her
plagues
as in the days of know and lot there
must be no compromise between god and
the world
no turning back to secure earthly
treasures
the people are dreaming of prosperity
and peace the multitudes cry peace and
safety while heaven declares that swift
destruction is about to come upon the
transgressor
in the night prior to their destruction
the cities of the plain rioted in
pleasure and derided the warnings of the
messenger of god but that very night the
door of mercy was forever closed
to the careless inhabitants of sodom god
will not always be mocked
now just this little portion over here
martin
come out of my people that you be not
partakers of our sins
and that you receive not of her plagues
is very problematic today
yeah it's causing a big stir in an
economical climate
this one
doesn't sit very well
it's a square peg in a round hole it
doesn't fit
and as that question
stated
then why are we involved
now some people believe
that
by being involved you can bring your
message across
now let me tell you one little story i
was in a northern country
let's leave it at that
let's not be too specific but let's talk
about
the stories
i'd been invited to come and do a public
campaign there
but before the campaign started
i was told
please don't say anything about
dairy
because that's the main food of the area
and
please don't say anything about
the papacy
or about babylon or coming out or
anything like that
because we have excellent relations
yeah
with the other
organizations
then i said
well
i don't see the point in holding a
public campaign because what i'm not
going to tell the people
if i don't warn them that there is a
problem and that they have to come out
yeah
so they arranged a meeting with the
leaders
and the leaders told me
that they were in a council group
with all the others
all the other churches
and that they had excellent relations
and that i should refrain from
mentioning anything of that nature
now
what is the three angels messages
yeah you cannot ignore it
you don't tell them what the beast is
and you tell them don't tell them what
the mark is and you don't tell them what
babylon is
how do you do that without you know
saying anything
so i said well how long have you had
these relations
they said 17 years
i said 17 years
and how many of those people have
been converted
to the truth
no none of them yet and i said your
method doesn't work sorry i don't rather
try mine
and
that didn't go down very well
so in the end
with
some
little adjustments here and there
i did actually hold the campaign
and i actually had baptisms
so
this is a very tricky issue depending on
how people feel
now having come out of babylon yeah
right
it was
hard for me to comprehend
that they would want to have good
relations with babylon how many
questions do you get from that
i get many many questions on that people
that come out of babylon now and can't
understand correct why
we're not talking correct now i've come
to the conclusion that many people
that do not understand the real
difference between what constitutes
babylon
and what constitutes the church
are inclined to move with
with echomanism and try to reach the
people in that way
i can tell you two stories from my life
i was invited to a former east bloc
country
and it's a very catholic country
and i was invited by
the seventh-day adventist
church to come and do
campaigns
in fact more than one in the area
but of course not everybody was happy
with me doing campaigns because
when i speak
i try to say how it is
doesn't sit too well with some of the
people
so i arrived in this country and it was
just after
the
the fall of the iron curtain
so what had happened all the properties
had been confiscated yes
but after
the iron curtain fell
the states gave the properties back but
some of the properties like churches for
example didn't exist anymore so they
gave them an equivalent building
and the leadership in this particular
country had received
what appears to be an apartment building
with a number of floors
and many
offices and things in it and that's
where it was housed
and in the first few days
i was housed there
that was a very strange experience
because i was supposed to go to the
countryside to go and do campaigns
but while i was there
they put me in a room
on the top floor
and the pastor in charge of this
building and what went on in there so it
was one of the high echelons of
leadership
he asked me
about my diet
and he'd heard that i am plant-based
and
it totally freaked him out
and he said to me that
he doesn't know what to do with me
and he doesn't think it will work well
that if i come to him to eat with him
because
his wife probably won't be able to
handle it that i'm plant-based i said
you know it's very easy you just
give me something
simple give me a potato i'll be happy
you don't have to stress about me just
give me a potato just put a potato on my
plate and i'll be happy
don't worry about it it's fine
but he shook his head and he was
absolutely horrified that someone could
live in this fashion
and so for that day
i got nothing to eat
and i waited patiently and the snow
outside was more than a meter deep
and i looked out
through the area through the window and
i could see nothing around except some
smoke over there maybe a tiny village
maybe two three kilometers away but this
building was basically by itself yeah
and uh then he arrived
and he says i don't know what to eat
what to feed you and we don't know what
to feed you and he grabbed put his hand
in his pocket and he put one roll
on my on my table he took it out of his
pocket and he put it down there
that was it
okay
and
he he just didn't know how to handle it
and so the second day he arrived and he
brought me
two dumplings
about the size
of a ball bearing
they looked like two eyes
and i thought okay
this is going to be interesting so i
took the two dumplings they fit it onto
a fork and i ate them
and
i was doing lectures
in the interesting thing is i was doing
health lectures
and every evening
he was there
in the front row he was a fairly large
man
but he did the introduction sat down and
within seconds he was asleep
and i was pretty hungry
because
i
just didn't receive anything and so
finally his conscience bothered him and
he said okay
he'll take me out to a restaurant
so that that's wonderful
we went to a restaurant
and he took me to a seafood restaurant
and he said to the waiter this man
is plot based he eats plots
so they said what do i eat does it
anything you know potatoes
anything rice vegetables anything like
that don't stress just you know
something something like that
and he ordered the seafood platter
and when the food arrived i had a big
plate with garnish on it
it was a sprig of carrot and there was a
little
slice of cucumber and a piece of lettuce
and a tiny half a tomato
this baby tomatoes cutting off it was
very decorative
but there was nothing of substance
and my stomach was grumbling like crazy
he got a bed of rice
i must say i coveted that bed of rice
and on it was everything
that moves within the sea
and he was from the church
yes yes he was the union pastor
and
i looked at it and i wondered
what's he going to do with it
i mean
there was calamari on the plate
there were prawns on the plate
there was everything on the plate that
shouldn't be on the plate
plus some things that were probably okay
but he consumed it all
without batting an eyelid
so it suddenly struck me
the poor man
has no idea
about the health message
he has no idea about clean and unclean
and
how can i expect him
to suddenly understand
where i come from now yeah all right
we're in two different planets
anyway
that evening i decided
because i have this nature
that i was going to give a lecture on
clean and unclean
but unfortunately it didn't help me
because after the introduction he fell
asleep
so he didn't hear it
but then something else happened
and this is years ago
now this is after the iron curtain fell
this is
very very long ago i i can't even
remember the date when it was
and it was in this building in the union
building
and i that was my last evening there
after my little lecture series there i
don't know what effect it had
and that evening
a pastor arrived who was going to take
me
on the campaign trail
and i met him there for the first time
very nice chat
and i chatted to him and he came and sat
next to me and they had a meeting
a public meeting
and it turned out to be an economical
meeting
now this is in the adventist church
right yeah
an economical meeting and i thought
this is very strange
but i was somehow involved because i sat
there in the audience
and then all
the church representatives came in and
the orthodox church and the various
protestant denominations and they all
sat down
and eventually the cardinal
of the roman catholic church and his
entourage
a number of
of priests and nuns arrived
and they were given the seats of honor
in the front row
and i looked at this pastor next to me
and i said
what's going on
here and he basically said to me
don't worry about it
they're all like this here just ignore
them
this was his attitude
and so
this thing continued
and then a spokesman from our church
greeted all the delegates
and he said that they were there for
economical discussions
and he greeted the the cardinal with so
much pomp
and with such flattering words
and
with such a plum
at the cardinal got up
and said i'm very surprised
i'm very surprised to have this
wonderful reception i didn't
know that the adventist church had such
economical
thinking patterns
and the man said yes absolutely we want
to embrace everybody and be part of this
etc etc
and and i was totally freaking
and then i heard words that nearly
caused my heart to stop
he said in fact
we have a guest here
a guest speaker from africa
and i'm sure that he would love
to convey the greetings of the african
brethren
to you your eminence would you please
come forward with a word of greetings
for the cardinal and the rest of the
delegates
i nearly died
the sweat came to my forehead
and i thought to myself what now
and i said you know to myself
and i only had a few minutes because i
now have to get up and walk the length
of the hall to go to the front
and i said to myself
lord
help
the three angels messages won't go down
well here
i think i can forget about the third
angel's message
and the second angel's message will be a
catastrophe now
so
what can i do only the first angel's
message remains
so
by the time i got to the front i sort of
had half an idea of what i would say
and i said to all the delegates
not addressing him in particular but all
of them collectively
and i said
many greetings
from the african continent
to all present who love the everlasting
gospel
[Laughter]
may those who love the everlasting
gospel
find unity
in that gospel
and welcome from africa and i went and
sat down
and i thought that was genetic
definitely it uh embraced everything
that i believed and didn't deny anything
that i believed
and you got the first angel's message
and i and i got a portion a tiny little
portion of the first angel's message
messaging
so then we left there and
we went on the campaign trail
the pastor took me with him
but what a contrast
it was like day
and night
and
the communities at that stage
after the fall of the iron curtain were
still very poor
and when we arrived in these places
the hospitality
the way in which they
they treated you the food that they
supplied
they were vegetarian
and they were
they were so kind and they were so
joined together in a common bond
and it was one of the most marvelous
things
and i met all of these people and i
realized
that there's a huge disconnect
between what's happening on the ground
and what's happening in some other
circles that was quite an extreme case
and that but that gave you a foundation
of
for future correct um episodes that
would happen correct
now i never met any of the other people
really i was only assigned to
this
one individual in the leadership
position and this one pastor
and i met the people with him and other
pastors of other churches and they were
all on the same page
they all believed
what the bible and the spirit of
prophecy said
all right maybe
you know they didn't have all the things
together but they had such a heart for
the message
and it gave me great courage
so that's just one of the issues
regarding the ecumenical council
and we'll come to some more examples
like that and that started off with the
health message that's supposed to be
universal through the church correct but
you can understand that if you come from
some of those backgrounds
that
you know you can't know all the details
and does god hold everybody responsible
because he's not on the same page of
course not he only holds you responsible
when you've had the light and and you
reject it
now when it comes to the first world
then things are very different because
the first world was supposed to be
informed
and when i started lecturing
more than 30 years ago
and i came to the continent of europe
again
30 years ago
the bulk of the people
were on the same page when it came to
the truth
but when it came to
some of the
the leading brethren
and even our colleges
that was a different story
now not everybody was off the page but
many were one of my first experiences
i came to one of our colleges
in in europe
i might as well say in which country it
was in germany
and
in our own college i was vehemently
attacked for
opposing the evolution theory
in fact
i was lecturing at uh one of our
colleges i gave a lecture
and
most of the students walked out they
said they will not listen to something
that's so ridiculous as a creation
account
now that's a fundamental belief of the
church right it's the first angel's
message and i just come
out of a
world of evolution
and i was i was
flabbergasted that some people in our
colleges would be like that
but i gave a series and eventually they
were all sitting and listening so that's
fine
but it wasn't always that easy
so
initially
everybody was working in the churches
and the churches by and large believed
the same thing the people
believed if they were part of the
seventh-day adventist church they
believed in creation
they believed in a six-day creation they
believed in a young earth
but it wasn't the case in some of the
higher echelons yeah so
there's again this
notion that
the church official statement is
creation in literal six days correct but
still there were some
even in leadership positions that not
were not adhering to correct
now if i if i look at my own situation
what were the issues that created the
most problems
number one
young earth
creationism
people didn't have a problem per se
within the church with creationism but
when it comes to the mechanism of
creation they had major problems they
wouldn't believe
many of them in six literal day creation
the other issue was
that
i
brought to the table plot based
completely plant that based diet
which was incomprehensible
because everybody was on dairy
and so this created a major conflict
in fact
when i went on my very first
evangelistic trip to the north american
continent
letters were sent ahead don't ever let
that man speak
on health issues
because he's dangerous
he'll tell you that dairy is bad for you
yeah and this from your own conference
your own conference yes but there in the
spirit of prophecy
it says that cheese should never be
introduced into the human stomach right
correct and god's commandment keeping
people at the end of time will not eat
anything that comes from an animal even
milk and eggs and all of these things
will be given up
but cheese should never enter the human
stomach totally unfit for food correct
so i had all of that
plus i'd started my own research program
and had come to the conclusion
that no matter how flabbergasting that
was to me personally and that
i had to change my life
i found it even a harder pill
for those within the church to swallow
that so that was a major bone of
contention
and then the third one
was secret societies
don't you dare speak about secret
societies
many were uncomfortable with a very
direct approach on what constitutes
babylon
we shouldn't do that we should have
the soft approach don't bring a message
that says
babylon has fallen you should you should
just
live the example
and people will accept the truth all by
themselves you know like that that no
northern country where they've done that
for 17 years and they've been no result
right
so those are the issues and these issues
are in the church to this very
day
and most of them
have probably been
for years even before you came into the
church correct
and
you know when when i came
into this truth
i was in this truth for a very short
time
when i had that miracle
where our university suffered under
riots and they closed the university for
six weeks
and i could attend
the geoscience institute
in california
and go into the field with godly people
that believed in a six-day creation
and we went on this field trip together
and we went to many many geological
sites
and the insight and the clarity
that these people had and the faith that
they had made a great impression on me
but not everybody shared their sentiment
even within the same academic
institutions
so i realized there was a major war not
only outside but inside the church
and then a few years later
i attended faith and science meetings
and at these faith and science meetings
my eyes
were really opened
and
i realized how deep this problem
actually is
so martin on this issue let's just read
another quote from the spirit of
prophecy before we continue the story
this one comes from letters and
manuscripts volume 14.
great efforts are made in this age to
induce ministers to leave the
straightforward path of truth and
holiness
in order to sustain a wrong course of
action many praise the minister
who dwells on the grace and mercy and
love of jesus
who is not particular
to enforce duties and obligations who
does not warn of the danger of hypocrisy
or present the terrors of god's wrath
the lord's work is earnest and decided
above deceit and hypocrisy
his true shepherds will not praise and
exalt man they will come before the
people with the plane thus says the lord
the holy one of israel
they will bear his message where the men
will hear or whether they will forebear
if men despise god's word and trust in
oppression hypocrisy and worldliness
they must declare against them god's
denunciation so that if possible
they may be aroused to repentance
if they are too proud to repent and
confess their errors to turn to god
welcoming his salvation and seeking his
favor
the lord will remove his light from them
and will leave them to walk in the way
they have chosen
so you were invited to
the faith and science meetings correct
and
to which ones were did you well there
were faith and science meetings on every
continent
the issue was do we still believe in the
six day creation so this was the church
this was the whole church the faith and
science meetings is within the church
this was organized from the highest
level from the general conference do we
still believe
and what is our issue on this
on this important subject what is our
principle of faith
because as i said there were so many
of our colleges they were teaching
evolution
which is totally contrary to the spirit
of prophecy yes
but
how this came about i was on another
continent
well i might as well say which one it
was it was australia now i could only
go
on evangelistic campaigns during
university recesses yeah because you
were working full-time i was working
full-time
at the university so i only had
relatively short periods of time
so the interesting thing is
if it didn't fit into that time slot
i couldn't go right
now my first visit to geoscience
didn't fit into that time slot but the
lord opened the door through riots and
there was a six weeks time slot that
normally would not be available which
enabled me to go
and i met these
these wonderful people
that were
creationists
and had written wonderful books on
creation evolution
and i'd read many of those in the past
but they never impressed me but these
people
had such a
beautiful foundation and such a firm
faith
that it was very very useful to me
and
i realized that there are
are people that from a scientific point
of view can
fully embrace the word of god in the
spirit of prophecy
so you had this conflict in the
beginning because that you had people
that were believing in evolution and
creation correct now you've got your
faith back in the denomination well
let's put it this way i'd accepted it
already but there were many gaps in my
knowledge
and even after that there were still
gaps in my knowledge but eventually
you know you could work your way through
and become grounded in the fact that you
can trust the bible and the spirit of
prophecy correct so i had this
invitation
to
australia
but again
there were letters that preceded my
visit
which dealt with a health issue
don't let that man talk about health
and so my reception
was very cool
to say the least
from a leadership level where these
letters had arrived right
they came from various sources these
letters because you know the
the all plant-based diet the vegan diet
was
something which was incomprehensible to
many many people except the new ages in
this world
but within the church it was not exactly
accepted and so my reception was very
cool
but they were happy to let me you know
speak on issues like creation evolution
and things like that but i was
definitely not very welcome
when it came to some of the other topics
and
i was invited to speak at one of our
large universities in that country
and i went to the science department
and i gave a few lectures on creation
evolution
now what would you expect would be the
response in an institution that
supposedly believes in the bible and the
spirit of prophecy you would think that
it would have a favorable reception if
you can provide evidence upon evidence
upon evidence that the bible
is
based on truth right
anything but
my reception was
very cold indeed
except for
one of the individuals
who was very pro
and
he was quite a new convert
and and something struck me there
in in some of our institutes of higher
education
the inroads of the worldly thinking
had
had crept in
[Music]
and people were reluctant to
be ridiculed
because they had a different point of
view right
so i felt there was quite a bit of
animosity that built up there but this
story has an interesting twist
so while i was there i visited
the place where ellen white lived when
she was in that country
and
she lived in a place called in a house
called sunnyside which today is a museum
and i went with my wife to that museum
and i thought well this is wonderful now
i can take you know lots of pictures
because i have evangelism in my mind
and how to bring the truth across
to the secular world
we were there and looking at all the
details and taking pictures
and there were displays of some of the
dresses that she wore and you know you
had this image of
this very austere lady who only wears
black etc and here were dresses that had
some color in them and were you know
quite quite interesting for that time
period
and there was a man he was watching us
and he turned out to be the curator
of that particular place
and he didn't know who we were
and so we as we were walking around
taking pictures he asked us you know
where are you from and we told him where
we're from
and then he said why why are you so
interested in what you're doing
why are you taking all these pictures
so i told them well i might use them at
some stage for evangelism
they say so
do you have faith in the spirit of
prophecy
and i said absolutely
i mean i started my research
based on
what it says in the spirit of prophecy
and i had all these students working on
projects
uh trying to show that that which which
it said there
was actually factual and all of these
results were coming in
and i was just totally
totally blown away
by the precision
of the spirit of prophecy
and i consumed everything that i could
we read and we read and we read
and uh
when we felt that our lives were not in
harmony with what it says it was it
wasn't a rebuke it was like a pleasure
yes i i i acknowledge the the feeling
as soon as you get that
what you what what must i actually do
correct it's yes
no at least i know now i know i mustn't
do this i must do that thank you now now
why must i do that
why why is this better than that i took
that to the laboratory exactly and then
you get the facts and then i found that
out
this is why it's like this and
you know just my faith just grew
and suddenly this man starts crying
what's wrong he's the creator
and he says hardly anybody believes that
anymore
and this is our college they
marginalizer they are ashamed of that
name
and they try to hide it
and they even grow plants and things in
front of
of
memorials to to this name they're
ashamed of it
and it suddenly struck me you know all
is not well
and i realized you know it is so
and then something very interesting
happened
uh
before
this meeting
i was this visitor from africa right
they had their problems with the health
issues but you know
i was still quite accepted
they'd asked me
whether i would give the opening address
when the university opened because i was
there at the time
they were also in recess and they were
going to be opening and whether i would
give the opening address and i said sure
i would
but after those meetings with the
science faculty
the wind changed
the
the atmosphere grew frosty
and uh it was it was something to deal
with not with the people right with the
people where we were doing the campaigns
it was wonderful
and also the pastors that we were
working with it was wonderful
but the atmosphere at the institution
became somewhat frosty
and so one day i got a phone call and
they said
something has happened
and
you are no longer required to give that
opening address
one of the leading figures in the
establishment will do that
you're no longer required your services
are no longer required
so i said that's fine and i thought you
know why and
sort of figured out why but nevertheless
the day arrived when it should be this
talk but it was the night before
and in the middle of the night
i'm sleeping in a hotel room
i get a phone call
and
the the person on the other side are you
so and so and i said yes i'm wealthified
and he said
something has come up the person who was
going to give the opening address
has been called away because of a death
in his family
are you still available to do it
i i don't know what time it was could
have been two o'clock in the morning
and i said uh sure if you're going to
arrange so they can get there no that'll
be fine
so i think it's a question of the left
hand not knowing what the right hand is
doing
they suddenly had a crisis and somebody
remembered that i had been asked
but that i had been cancelled maybe i
was still available but they didn't know
the reasons why
i had been cancelled whatever the
reasons
were and so
i arrived there that morning to give the
opening address
and
some of the people at the institution
had a look of horror on their faces
and they went i was supposed to speak
for 40 minutes
and
my wife and i were sitting in the
audience
waiting for the events to start
and the students were all there
and i saw this little huddle over there
of some of those brethren
and they were having a rather
heated discussion
and then one of them sided up to me and
said
he's terribly sorry
but
something important has come up
and they won't be able to give me 40
minutes anymore
would i be able to do it in 10.
so
my speech that i had prepared for the
opening address
was whittled down to 10 minutes which
made it totally useless
and then he left
and they went back into their little
huddle
and the something important that had
come up
was a music festival
that resembled more of a pop culture
festival than anything else they brought
the drums onto the stage etc etc
and for the time that i was supposed to
speak
they
had a medley of music
so i knew that there was an
interposition there
so when the time arrived
i thought you know what message can i
leave for these students what can i do
in 10 minutes 10 minutes is not a long
time you know it flies for you it's
definitely another long time yeah you
know i'm not long-winded
10 minutes okay
so i arrive on the stage
and i greet everybody present and then i
started giving a very brief
introduction as to where i came from in
the world
how i'd
come to embrace the truth
why i now believed in creation
and why the bible and the spirit of
prophecy are absolutely trustworthy when
it comes to creation
and i stuck my finger out like this and
i said to the youth you are all here at
an adventist
institution
and if anybody should ever tell you that
god did not create in six days then
don't listen to them
they don't know what the truth is you
can trust your bible and the spirit of
prophecy and i made one or two
more of those
noises and then they all got up and
clapped and i had done my 10 minutes and
walked off
and there was much consternation because
that was
just a little bit too much right
and when i got outside with my wife to
leave
and an elderly gentleman came up to us
and burst into tears
and it was an old retired pastor
and he embraced me there and he said
thank you
thank you for putting
the bible and the spirit of prophecy in
the center of your talk
and i said who are you he says i'm a
retired pastor and i spent my time
talking to the students trying to
encourage them that they might still
believe the old truths
now
i don't know whether the situation has
changed whether it has not changed some
say it has changed
but that is my experience
now while i was there
i got this
invitation to attend the faith and
science okay
and so i could just finish the campaign
wonderful experience beautiful
experience with god's people
and i could get onto a plane cross the
pacific
and go to the united states still within
my framework that i was allowed to have
and spent those few days
at
the faith and science
now was that an eye-opener
because now you had scientists from
around the world
and
they were there from europe
from the various countries in europe
they were there from africa from south
america from the pacific region
and some of those very gentlemen that
i'd met
just recently were there
and
i realized that you know we're not
necessarily on the same side of the
fence regarding this issue
anyway those talks were fascinating
they were very frank and very open
and there were representatives there
from
various institutions from our
universities
from the large universities of
north america institutes from all over
the world
and it was a faith and science meeting
so there were a few hundred scientists
of which i was one and
there were a few other delegates from
the african continent
and it's interesting that
the the delegates from the third world
were mainly
pro
bible and spirit of prophecy when it
came to this issue
but some of the lectures that took place
were
well to put it mildly horrifying
horrifying
some of the representatives the editors
of our liberal magazines
made no bones about it that they didn't
believe the creation account at all
in fact they told us quite blatantly
that they didn't believe in the spirit
of prophecy
that
they didn't believe at all that it was
inspired
maybe it was a good old lady but that's
it
uh they weren't even impressed with our
doctrines when it comes to
the doctrine on
on the state of the dead for example
and i thought
are these people seventh day adventists
and and they represent our magazines and
their editors of some of our magazines
when i when i came into that conference
the delegate from europe
came up to me
i didn't know the man
but i realized that he had quite a
fair amount of animosity in him
he shouted at me in the hall in front of
hundreds of people
my wife and i came in with our bags
because we've just come from australia
and
normally i would probably have been
invited alone but my wife was with me on
this trip so she was allowed to attend
and he walks up to after me and shouts
in my face
i eat meat
i said who are you and you know
see vaike if you eat meat what's your
problem
and so i thought i was a strange fellow
and i went and booked in
and i didn't know he was at that stage
and then i went into the escalator after
i'd you know received the keys to my
room
and the doors were about to close and he
ran up this is now the the
representative of europe right
he puts his foot in the escalator so the
doors open again
and there's about 12 people in the
escalator including my bags and my wife
and other people
and he shouts
you and your stupid ellen white
i thought you know that's that's rather
primitive
anyway the doors closed and i ignored
him and i only later found out who he
was
now some of the talks there were so
pro-evolution
the dean of medicine of one of our
large colleges there
he gave a talk which was not only
pro-evolution but was blatantly
pantheistic and pan-anthiastic
and
everybody
looked at this and
most of them seemed perfectly at ease
with it
except one man he was a representative
from holland
and he got up and he made a speech
and he started crying
and this made a tremendous impact on the
meeting
because he said you know
i sent my child
to one of these institutes
and i sent her their believing
faithful christian
and she came home an atheist
and an
evolutionist and now i can see that you
know many of these leading brethren here
teach exactly the same thing
there i realized
that
the golden
cough that you were not allowed to touch
was short chronology of the earth
[Music]
they were quite happy to have the
sentence
in our belief system
that god created in six days
but you tried to put that little word
literal
into that equation
and there was consternation
the polarization
was absolutely enormous
and
you know these people that were
pro-evolution came from our leading
colleges
one of them a north american one
was well known for its stand on
evolution
saying that the universities of the
world will find us ridiculous if we
stand for
creation and they vehemently opposed it
and i knew some of the lectures because
i dealt with some of them before
and i knew
what their view was
they were blatantly against the spirit
of prophecy and the bible
why i'm telling you this martin is
all of these
individuals
are in this gospel net yeah
unfortunately
in many of our colleges
where they want to have academic
recognition
it seems that they might be
more of the one kind than the other kind
and i remember having a meeting with
concerned brethren
in one of the rooms where the people
were absolutely
shocked
at what was coming up
and what people believed and
i thought to myself you know
why are these people in the church they
don't believe the spirit of prophecy
they don't believe what the bible says
what are they doing here you know that's
what comes to mind and this is exactly
what these people are asking i don't
think it's an unfair question no it's
not an unfair question
but then over time i realized suddenly
that god
allows these conflicts within the church
to arouse
the thinking of humanity
and he allows the two sides
to present their cases
so that people can make informed
decisions yes
now one of our colleges who which in my
opinion was the most apostate concerning
the creation evolution debate
uh a north american one
was of course
would be very antagonistic to the view
which i have which is i believe what the
bible and the spirit of prophecy says
right
i got an invitation from that university
by the
youth by the student league to come and
speak there on more than one occasion
and there was huge consternation
the leadership didn't want me to speak
but the students said you're not allowed
to prescribe to us we're an independent
body and we want him to speak
and so i went there
and
it was amazing
the students were all there but all of
those individuals were also sitting
there
and
i was allowed to state my case and i
stated the case for creation i made
quite a strong appeal to to the student
body to believe the bible and the spirit
of prophecy and not to be
indoctrinated into believing
that this was a figment of the
imagination
and
if you look at how some of these people
reacted how they would prompt students
to ask questions
which you wouldn't even expect in the
secular world
questions so antagonistic to the gospel
even antagonistic to jesus christ
that i was absolutely horrified and said
you know if this is the kind of
sentiment that is being taught you in
this institution
if this is what you're picking up in
this institution i advise you to leave
it
don't attend it
and if you do attend it
then please be grounded in the bible in
the spirit of prophecy
now is that divisive
that's re-establishing truth putting it
in its right place correct
so this war this creation evolution
debate
rages at every level
even in my own country
i gave the courses at our colleges
on faith and science
for a number of years in a row while i
was working for the university i did it
as a favor
but when my my duties at the university
became too much
others took over and they taught
evolution again
so
there's been a backwards and a forwards
then again it goes back to creation then
it goes back to evolution depending on
who's in charge of the course
and this is something that will rage in
the church till the end of time
now my question
do i leave the church because there are
people within the church who fight
against the doctrine of creation
you're still sitting here i'm still
sitting here because there are thousands
that believe it i go to one university a
north american university a very large
one
i'm in the one institute
and everybody believes exactly the same
including myself
we're like like
brothers and sisters
we're on the same page
you cross
the passage
into the other section
you're an enemy terrain
how dare you speak about creation in
this way you're making a fool of of us
we will be ridiculed in the eyes of the
world
now excuse me if you believe in
thousands of years
that's ridiculous
if you're going to go the way of the
world then at least believe in millions
and millions and millions of years right
why sit between two chairs and
this issue has been going on what was
the final decision at faith and science
we believe in a six-day creation that's
it
they don't like the word literal
but they had votes on that later
they had votes on it
and
at different meetings with delegates
from all over the world
and they vote they vote with cards
yellow cards or different color cards to
vote yes or no
and there are videos of that and you can
watch it
and you can see the european delegates
and some of them from the pacific and
some of them from north america and they
vote against it
they don't believe in a six day creation
a literal six-day creation but the
overwhelming majority
believed it
do i leave the church because some of
the representatives
want to be in favor with the world
even if it is
the leadership well it was the
leadership
it was a large proportion of the
you don't leave the church okay
now
what do i do in a case like that that's
what a lot of people want to know
that's what that's the question right
what do i do in a case like that well
the answer is
i believe in the bible and the spirit of
prophecy and the bible of the spirit of
prophecy tells me that god has a church
that has a three angels message warning
for the last
generation and the first angel says
worship god and give him the glory
and don't worship the universal soup out
of which humanity
crawled in evolutionary stages
so that is a matter of choice
i am not going to leave the truth
because there are people even in high
places who don't embrace it
because there are people in high places
that do embrace it yes
because i've spoken to them
and
they will tell you to your face that
they do not agree
what is happening with what is happening
in some of these high places
so that is the issue
many of god's people will find that they
come up against brick walls
and that people
will try to marginalize them or limit
them
when it comes to speaking on these
issues so let's read another statement
from the spirit of prophecy letters and
manuscripts volume 14
from 1899
those who drive the lord's faithful
messengers into corners
who discourage them who stand between
them and the people
that their message may not have the
influence god designed it should
are answerable for the deceptions and
heresies that come into the church as a
result of their course
that's pretty
straightforward right
they have a fearful account to render to
god
after the lord has repeatedly warned his
people and they still refuse to hearken
to his voice
and will not be instructed their guilt
becomes peculiarly abhorrent to him
the record of their rebellion is written
in a book before him
and will confront them when the judgment
shall sit and the books shall be opened
so in the interim
i have come to the conclusion
that throughout every single echelon
from the highest level of the general
conference
to the lowest level of the poorest
church in the world
there will be people
that will stand
on either side of this issue
and god will decide how this issue will
be resolved
you see if you if you start with the
reformation
whenever there were people that didn't
agree
they started the new dominant
denomination correct
and so it went on and even in that
denomination eventually
somebody they split again correct
so now we've got god's church and if you
split it up
eventually even those that thought now
we are
we've got it all
will eventually also split up because
they will come some division there as
well correct that's why you've just
shown us that say
god will sort out what has to be sorted
correct
now if i take the faith and science
meetings
the representative from europe
when the vote event eventually went to
we believe
in the creation account in the six day
creation account
uh he got up and complained bitterly
that he cannot take a decision back to
europe
where obviously you know with their
with their advanced uh stage of of
knowledge on the issue they would not
accept such a ridiculous
uh thing that what is what is even more
interesting martin
is that these delegates
that supposedly represent the church in
europe
actually represented themselves because
the people on the ground yeah we weren't
in harmony with what they were
propagating
so
i've come to the conclusion that this
war rages in the church now it rages on
every single
level
when it comes to the to the health issue
that is a war
don't touch someone's plate
and as i said before
when i watched those delegates
what was in the mind was often directly
proportional to what was on the plate
and it was it was a was a hotel
and they had you know common meals so
you could see what was on the plates not
that i would you know want to judge
entirely by what was on the plate but it
just was interesting that that which
came out of the mouth
very often correlated with that which
was on the plate
and
when i started off with the with the
health lectures in europe
and in the pacific and in north america
there were very many that would oppose
it vehemently
even to the point of trying to get
worldly institutions to to ridicule it
which often backfired on them very
severely so if god wants a message out
he'll get it out if he wants the
creation evolution debate
to become prominent
what better way than to create
opposition to it yeah
because
everything will be for the truth again
exactly so once the war rages on this
issue
and people see
there is a conflict here
within the church
they will actually be forced to make
their own personal decision for one side
or the other right
and that is the way god uses us the same
with the health message
now people will say that splitting the
church no
it is providing information
i want upon which people make a decision
and the decision that they make
will put them on opposite ends of those
that make the contrary decision yes so
yes jesus said the gospel is a sword yes
that divides to the marrow and by making
something prominent
you are actually
furthering the cause of god you can do
nothing against the cause of god you can
only do something
for it now if you take these things
personal
and you take their tax personal because
some of these attacks then will become
very personal yes most of the times and
it's the same
throughout the world yes when they can't
pinpoint you on the facts
it's got starts getting personal it has
to get personal and sometimes the
personal remarks start hurting
so some of these people
in our magazines are liberal magazines
and we have liberal magazines
they will say the most horrendous things
hurtful things
i remember in europe
the first time i was there in the winter
i was in a northern country in germany
or in the northern region of germany
they're up against the north sea
and the north sea was frozen over
now i come from africa yeah have you
ever seen an ocean frozen over martin
no never have you ever seen a lake
frozen over no no
so we're not used to that right
and here the whole ocean was frozen over
and you could walk
to the ships
out in the ocean
now we didn't walk they were quite far
away but you could walk up to them the
ocean was frozen
now they took me out on the ice and i i
walked on the north sea
what an experience for someone who comes
from hot africa right
so in one of my sermons i said
it was an amazing experience to think
that you could walk on the ocean
frozen over for me that was amazing
next thing they publish
in one of their liberal magazines what a
fight says he is jesus christ he can
walk on water
so that's the kind of thing that they do
so you can take that
personal and
or you can ignore it on the health issue
after i'd left and given my health
lectures which created quite a stir of
course
the funny thing is 33 years later
everybody accepts that this is the
healthiest lifestyle
but in the beginning it was a war
um isn't it 34 years by now but just
just now
on some of the tablets it will be saying
33 what the fight's declaring is a three
mice
anything is possible
but the interesting thing is
i got back to africa
and some of these
magazines who were writing
that i had suddenly become very sick
because of adopting this health healthy
lifestyle right yeah
this
total plant-based diet i had become very
sick
and
eventually these articles
escalated
and then eventually
they said walter fight has said to the
world please ignore what i have said
everything is wrong i'm very sick
because i've changed my lifestyle
and then the very next thing that
happened they said he's dead
he died
and so
we got phone calls from europe
and my wife picked up the phone and this
person said we're so sorry to hear that
your husband
is dead what happened how did it happen
and she said why why no because you know
his lifestyle and he recanted and said
that was wrong his lifestyle
and my wife said well
just hang on a moment
and she gave the phone to me and i said
hello what what's this what's going on
and they wouldn't believe it was me
and i said i'm alive and well
and i'm still on my lifestyle thank you
very much and i'm very happy to be on it
whoever wrote that
is uh either ill-informed or is
mischievous
in some way or other
so these are the kinds of things that
happen
so now martin do i leave the church
because someone has lost his mind and
and
publishes something like that
no
of course not right definitely not okay
because that is something to try and
derail you
correct
so let's have a look at this statement
from letters and manuscripts volume two
it says satan has worked through his
various channels to accomplish his evil
work
god will permit men of limited
experience in every way to come in
men who do not know how to walk by faith
men who do not have the spirit of
self-denial and sacrifice
satan could insinuate himself
and a mold be given to the work and
workers contrary to that which the lord
has been constantly setting before his
people
in his word and through the testimonies
of his spirit
this is always the bottom line
no matter what the debate is whether it
be creation evolution
whether it be the health message
the issue is the word and the testimony
yes
that's the issue
that's your anchor that's it if you
throw that aside you will be adrift
without an anchor and you will be
drifting towards babylon and you can't
stand on only one
correct you have to have both legs
correct the word and the testimony and
the sad thing is i met people
in this faith and science debate
who were so firmly rooted on the side of
the bible and the spirit of prophecy
but when they were in the company of
this other group
they were swayed
and i went to the one and i said
i don't understand what happened to you
why are you why are you allowing this to
happen
why are you being swayed
and he looked down at the table and he
said
this is the omega
i said you know if you think this is the
omega
then why do you want to be part of it
then step out
put your faith in the bible in the
spirit of prophecy because your
compromise is not good enough it will
still make you ridiculous with the world
stand on the truth
and so this debate will rage in the
church
until the shaking is complete that's it
and there will eventually be those that
will say we don't want to stand with
those that are so ridiculous as to
believe in a literal six day creation
and others will say we don't want to
stand with those who say
that a healthy lifestyle in taking care
of your health and doing what is right
according to god's instructions is your
way to health
we don't want to stand with that we want
to stand with the world
and there will be people that will stand
on either side of the issue whatever the
debate is
and just because
we
hear many of these strange things
from men in leading positions it doesn't
make the church babylon it just means
that there are people who are either
confused or babylonians that are in the
church
you mentioned now that this will
continue on
until the end of the shaking correct
what constitutes the end of the shaking
the close of probation martin we had a
whole discussion on the shaking
it's in one of the what's-ups i don't
know which one it is
because we've had too many of late i
think it was 17 but i'm not too sure
whatever it says the straight testimony
will cause the shaking now what is the
testimony
all these truths all these truths and if
you stand doesn't mean that we'll agree
on every single point and have absolute
uh you know synchronized thinking
but the basic core will be we believe
what the bible and the spirit of
prophecy says
and that will cause the shaking and the
church will go through okay now let me
give you one more example
i was in another east block country
and
a former esport country it's now a
country that's part of the european
union
but
as with in the case of the other one
that i spoke about
i gave a series
and i spoke
like i always
i expose who babylon is
what the beast is etc etc
and
that doesn't go down well with everybody
and one of those meetings
one of the academics was actually my
translator
and i was lecturing to this audience and
i was speaking in english and he was
translating into the
language of the country
and he wasn't translating what i was
saying
but there were people in the audience
that were
capable of speaking english
and corrected them and said no no no no
no no that's not what he said
he didn't want to translate
when i said something that was very
direct or
that called the spade a spade or that
exposed the papacy as the beast he
didn't want to do it and so eventually
he got so annoyed he put the mic off and
he just walked off the stage which is
quite embarrassing right
and it's interesting to me
the one who came up and took the
microphone was the conference president
and
immediately the whole atmosphere changed
because he was on the exact same page
so does can you see not everybody in
leadership is necessarily on the other
side of the fence
and we had a great relationship now it's
also interesting i gave more lectures in
that particular country
and in one of the churches
that i was assigned to do a campaign in
the pastor was a young pastor
and he was
in my opinion extremely liberal
and his interest was music
and the guitar
and the message is secondary all you
have to do is
be happy
and have a nice worship session almost
charismatic
and that was all that was required
so he was not impressed by anything that
i said
and
he he was a young fellow and he
he wasn't rude
but he was obviously not on the same
page right
uh to the point that i could say that he
was annoyed
because this was ruffling feathers
and he didn't like it he wanted a nice
smooth calm
environment without any uh questions
that could cause controversy
what is that book that is written
isn't it called the great country the
great controversy correct so they they
didn't like controversy
and here towards the end of the meetings
which is now
a week or two later
suddenly his demeanor changed
and i thought
what happened did something i say get to
him
and he says he wants to talk to me
so i said okay
so when the people had left
he came and sat next to me
and he
started talking
and you know i wanted to flatter myself
that it was something that i had said
nothing
that i said impressed him
it wasn't me at all
he had a chat with his
grandmother who was well into her late
80s she was
a very old lady
and
she he was a grandson right
and she said to him after the meetings
she said to him now i can die in peace
because i know that the old adventist
message is still alive
and being preached in the world
and that shot an arrow
straight through him right yeah
so it wasn't what i had said his
grandmother it was the grandmother
and suddenly he realized
is that the advent message
and he started to think about it i don't
know what happened to the young man
but there was a total transformation
now one
if the great controversy hadn't come
to those meetings
would that grandmother have been able to
shoot that arrow no
now
the fact that he was not interested in
the beginning
i could see that as discouraging right
correct you could you could give up
yes and some people might give up right
if you have so much opposition
but this was to me a total confirmation
that god is there he's always working
and you mustn't judge someone by his
cloth
because you don't know
whether that young man will receive an
arrow through the heart
from something totally unrelated and all
of a sudden his whole life changes you
can have a paul experience
and and this is what people need to
understand in this church
they need to understand that the issues
are great
that there is
much reason
for division and argument
and there will be a decided development
of camps within the church
and the shaking will be a very painful
experience it won't be sunshine and
roses to go through no
no god never promised us a rose garden
and this is what i like about the bible
god is very honest he says in this world
you will have tribulation
and
do you think you can drink the cup well
if you think you can drink it indeed you
will drink it now
i've had many many experiences
with this church and with leadership and
i've had some
some
amazing experiences some of them i've
never shared
because i don't want to seem divisive
or seem to be running the church down
but sometimes
while
listening to what you've just shared
there's i
find encouragement and hope
again in stories yes and don't don't
write off everybody in leadership
because they take a position which
according to you is contrary to what you
think should have been taken right
and
i've had occasions where i've come into
severe conflict
which has caused much personal pain i
mean i've been banned right in countries
i have been accused i have been handed
over to authorities i've had many many
experiences some of them which have been
very very
hurtful
but the question is
what was the outcome of those
experiences
was it just the personal vendetta
against me or was there always
some or other important doctrinal
attribute that was attached to the event
in other words my question
should be
what was it
that god wanted to make prominent
through the event
and then the person
has to fade into
into the background
it's not important what happened to you
what is the outcome
did a particular issue become prominent
and perhaps we should talk about that in
another in another session because we
could go on
forever when it comes to these
experiences
and uh
you know i i've always been very
reluctant to talk about these
experiences
because people will say why are you
telling these things
well you know
i'm telling them because they happened
and i haven't told them thus far because
i thought
you know it might be hurtful
but
on on reflection
it might actually be helpful to some
people to understand
that we're dealing with a far greater
issue
than your own personal feelings
and when god deals with this church
everybody
from the highest to the lowest
is in the process
of molding
and you never know
when that dart experience will take
place you never know
and if there isn't a decision that has
to be made where you have to stand for
something even if it costs you
then how can an issue become prominent
so
when we try to answer the question of
these people why is this happening in
the church and why is that happening in
the church and why has leadership taken
this position and not that position
then i would like to encourage them
and say why has god permitted it
and what is he making prominent through
it
and how many people are taking a stand
because of it
not in a in a in a sense of declaring
war
against individuals but making a stand
for a particular truth for truth pretty
truth back where it's supposed to be
that's what we have to aim for
and
what would i
love
what would be
my ultimate reward in the world
if people would believe the bible and
the spirit of prophecy
if people would realize
the rest and the peace that you can have
if you know
that you were created in the image of
god
that you're not an afterthought yeah if
you can have a lifestyle that will keep
you healthy and protected
in the care of god and that you can
enjoy it and that he has provided yeah
and it's not it's not a suffering it's a
it's a it's an absolute joy if someone
could understand that and embrace it
instead of warring against it
but uh
nothing
in many aspects it's a pipe dream
because
you will have war
when it comes to dealing with a person's
plight
but when that person suddenly grasps it
then you will have you will have someone
who is in
perfect union
with your thinking and the thinking of
the bible and the spirit of prophecy but
then again he will have a war yes
whether the war comes from his
colleagues or whether it comes from his
friends or his family or his wife or his
children he's going to have a war and
he's going to have to fight it and see
his way through it
and what absolute joy he will experience
when one of of his loved ones
accepted
and and so the war will continue until
the last trump and it's interesting
the whole time you mentioned earlier
don't take this personal because the war
is not against you no it's if once you
make it a personal war you've lost the
war the war is against that book and the
spirit of prophecy correct and uh we'll
talk about some more stories i'm looking
forward to it let's close with the word
of prayer
heavenly father
you have a church and you have a truth
and you have penned it
lord in thousands and thousands of word
in your word and in the spirit of
prophecy
help us to
internalize it
try to understand it and when we do not
understand it ask for wisdom because you
have promised
that if we seek
we will find
and if we ask
you will answer
and i can testify in my own life lord
that that is very true whenever there
was doubt
you supplied the answer
and i pray
that your people will not
give up
because there is a discussion
raging
but that they will
stick to the truth
thy word is truth
thy testimonies are truth
help us to embrace them in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again